boah beantworte mal selber diese Frage
ja was soll ich das kann man nicht
beantworten beantworte ich muss auch
beantworten beantwortte es also wenn er
das Sehen woll was er dazu nicht sage
ich nicht zu dieser Frage sagt und zu
allen anderen Fragen Lotto jetzt gucken
und abonnieren nicht
vergessen okay ich weiß Bescheid du
weißt bescheid ich kenne das Spielchen
sehr schön soll ich selber aufmachen
oder darf ich nein du darfst s selber
aufmachen selber aufmachen das sind wir
haben uns wirklich Mühe gegeben dass war
ins Schwarze treffen ich hoffe es klappt
ich bin gespannt wenn ich gleich
weglaufe dann haben wir es geschafft
weglaufen muss jetzt kommt die erste
Frage die natürlich äh jemand stellt
denke ich der auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen sticheln will aber ich finde es
nicht schlimm hast du auch Fans die
älter sind als 16 also dazu kann ich nur
so viel sagen wie kommt einfach mal zu
meinen Konzerten da werdet ihr sehen
dass von sogar 13 aufwärts bis 40 alles
dabei ist das ist auch keine Story so
man sieht das auch bei den
Autogrammstunden da sind sehr viele
ältere Leute auch dabei und äh wenn du
dir wenn man sich mit der Musik einmal
kurz auseinandergesetzt hat wird man
sehr feststellen dass da der Horizont
eines 16-jährigen auch bei weiten
übertroffen wird von daher denke ich
habe ich viele Fans die über 16 sind gut
okay sehr schön ich geh auf diese rote
Fragen okay du darfst aber auch grüne
ziehen ja ich will aber auch ein
bisschen diese roten Fragen gut okay
sehr sch ich mag dieses gehässige gut
das freut mich in den Leuten wecken ja
wir sind die einzige Show glaube ich in
den deutschen Medien die nur also die
diese Rubrik hat wo so viele gehäige
Fragen ja das kann gut sein aber das
macht euch wahrscheinlich auch hier ist
eigentlich die Frage finde ich ganz Z
welche Drogen hast du noch nicht
genommen also ich finde ich bin
eigentlich ein sehr bohenständiger Typ
ich bin sehr nah an der Realität dran
welche Drogen ich noch nicht genommen
habe sind auf jeden Fall Drogen wie LSD
solche Sachen würde ich niemals nehmen
und ich würde es auch niemals empfehlen
es gibt viele Drogen die ich noch nicht
genommen habe aber das ist so privat
dass ich sag so mach dir einfach ein
Bild guck mir in die Augen dann weißt du
welche Drogen ich genommen habe und
welche nicht okay gut eine grüne Frage
also was ich sagen kann du bist auf
jeden Fall kein intensiver Kiffer nee
das bin ich nicht das merkt man
sofort die sind da so ein bisschen R
bisschen gechillter wer dich in deiner
Jugend dazu inspiriert HipHop zu hören
und dann auch zu machen also bei mir war
es so wir waren halt wir kam aus so ein
bisschen ein Randbezirk so und da war
halt nur ein Jugendhaus genau Gladbeck
gelsen Kirchen in die Ecke so das ja im
Rot grenzt alles nah aneinander und da
war es halt so dass es ein Jugendhaus
gab wo die Elteren halt gebreakt haben
das war so Anfang 90er Mitte 9 er diese
Welle wo wirklich dieses Breakdance hier
rumging und ich war ein kleiner höppig
und ich durfte eigentlich gar nicht da
rein aber ich habe mich trotzdem da
reinemurelt okay sahst du älter aus oder
nee ich habe mich einfach reingemuch
kannte den einen oder anderen der ein
Auge zugedrückt hat und ich habe es mir
angeguckt und ich fand es einfach cool
so bin ich zu HipHop gekommen aber dann
selber HipHop zu machen ist viel später
passiert und auch aus ganz anderen
Gründen wie dieser Fußballgeschichte
dass es da nicht geklappt hat und ich
dann diese musiksache ernster genommen
habe um mich so den Leuten mitzuteilen
wie fängt das an das frage ich mich
immer wann setzt man sich zum ersten Mal
hin versucht was zu reimen und wann hat
man so das Gefühl ja ich versuch weil
ich allein schon im eigenen Zimmer sich
dahinzustellen und zu da braucht man
doch Überwindung oder also ich habe
dafür keine Überwindung gebraucht ich
war jemand ich habe auch wirklich mit 12
13 Jahren diesen coolen Rapper diese
coolen Rapper im Fernsehen nachimitiert
auch wenn es total bescheuert war und
ich habe irgendeine Fantasiesprache
gerappt die es eigentlich gar nicht gab
so das ist wirklich wirklich so gewesen
ich habe es aber erst viel später so
gecheckt was da abgen gerade und im
Nachhinein ist dann aus mir ein Rapper
geworden so deswegen denke ich mal so
ist schon auch eine Angelegenheit des
Menschen der eine ist steht nicht gerne
im Vordergrund der andere steht gerne im
Mittelpunkt und
teilt sich gerne mit und der andere sagt
ey ich mache lieber deine Musik und ich
will auch gar nicht überall erkannt
werden das ist nicht mein Ding kann ich
auch verstehen und respektieren Hal
nicht jederman Sache noch will sie alle
beantworten nee eine mache ich noch eine
rote noch eine gehässige
gut dann gucken wir
mal
kein Bock auf die Frage voll die dumme
Frage machen wir doch lieber eine grüne
sieh du sie sind so gehässig die sind
einfach nicht Gönner nicht Gönner was
macht dich so einzigartig also die Frage
ist leicht zu beantworten schau in diese
wunderschönes Gesicht und dann weißt du
was mich so einzigartig macht mE fre wie
kriegt man das eigentlich hin die gerade
Kante beim Rasieren wirklich ich muss
eigentlich jetzt zu dieser Schande
gestehen heute ist noch nicht mal im
perfek
also ich leg da Wert drauf dass ich aber
das ist für mich selber das ist einfach
etwas was ich mir gönne ein einmal
mindestens die Woche zum Friseur zu
gehen okay um mir da mein Chuck
abzuholen mein individuelles Aussehen
also ich brauche das um mich
wohlzufühlen wenn alles gerade getrimmt
ist wenn meine Konturen stehen W meine
Haare gerade sitzen dann freut mich das
das macht mich glücklich andere gehen
dafür unter die Sonnenbank der andere
geht dafür jeden Tag ins cffe ich gehe
gerne zum Friseur und lebt dort mein
Leben aus okay meine Fantasien dann in
diesem Sinne viel Spaß noch beim dan
danke sehr B